hi welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and X-Men first Class
director Matthew vaugh has not only seen
footage of Deadpool 3 but mentions how
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman are about
to save the whole Marvel Universe
literally or figuratively also why is
Matthew Von giv viant access to Deadpool
3 if he's only directed one X-Men movie
What notes or blessings would Matthew
Von lend to Shan Levy or Ryan Reynolds
what are we doing are we addressing the
Wolverine cameo in first class
orchestrating the Cuban Missile Crisis
or saving Darwin I will figure it out in
this video and we'll solve this riddle
together and don't forget to tune in to
Eric three breakdowns of the X-Men film
series on the new Rockstar Channel I
explore many of those breakdowns that
help me break this one down today and
it's important to get ready for Deadpool
3 and if you've forgotten some of those
nostalgic character story lines it's
just great to go back and watch them but
first be sure to check out the nerd r.
shop to check out our latest and
greatest and new rockstars merch right
now you can grab our Multiverse tour
shirt featuring many eras of Deadpool it
also comes as a hoodie or a crop top or
maybe pick up our Madam web shirt
featuring the greatest line from any
movie trailer in history I'm wearing it
right now and baby that line is going to
haunt me forever grabbing some merch
From Nerd ride. shop is the best way to
support the channel and all the hard
work we do here at new rock stars and me
bring these videos to you otherwise I
don't know what I'd be doing crawling on
the ground let's get into it Matthew
vaugh isn't the director of Deadpool 3
which I should probably have started
this all with it's sea Levy he's
directing Deadpool 3 but on the Bro
Bible post credit podcast he spoke on
Deadpool 3 he said the few Snippets that
I know about Deadpool vers Wolverine are
unbelievable that's going to be the jolt
the Marvel universe is about to have and
it's going to bring that body back to
life Matthew vau was originally hired to
direct X-Men the Last Stand after Brian
Singer left on the franchise to work on
Superman Returns vau left X-Men 3 after
citing how the execs messed it up and
were tricking Hal Berry they were trying
to use a script that had a bigger role
for storm that they never intended on
shooting in order to trick Hal Barry
into joining this project Bon didn't
like that so he walked he was then
brought back to the franchise to revive
it with X-Men first Class so why would
Matthew Von get some sneak peek footage
or details of Deadpool 3 if he's only
worked on that one movie well our first
observation would probably be to get
their blessing or notes real real
istically I think it's General consensus
that Logan X2 days of Futures Past first
class and the first X-Men movie are the
better ones and of those five two of
those directors haven't been cancelled
yet for any horrible thing so that's
Matthew vaugh and James Mangold so to
the public eye it makes sense that Ryan
Reynolds and Sean leevy consider talking
to Von for notes I personally love first
class I know it's not everyone's
favorite but he's probably the best
director of the X-Men like liveaction
Universe to talk to about anything X-Men
related he's also worked as a director
and writer for kickass and The Kingsmen
I just think he's good at blowing out if
this is true then what else is and
building likable characters and getting
them future movies he's like a weirdly
sufficient code for box offices and I
just like his action Parts in movies
that's important because he mentioned
how fans would love the Snippets of
Deadpool vers Wolverine like how they're
actually fighting and those characters
stand their own ground they can't always
just be battling one-on-one in the sand
we need them to actually Bend and go
somewhere else and I think Matthew Von
would be good leading some information
for that now I won't show the set leaked
photos from Deadpool 3 still we expect
to see some Cameo appearances from the
those set photos and different publicity
articles saon has probably glimpsed
scenes involving his first class
characters now I don't think he gets
100% saying and what they do with his
characters but if specific scenes from
first class need to be matched like this
scene with Wolverine which will probably
happen it's easiest for production to
shoot it like they did the original and
they probably asked Matt for advice or
the process behind it or any info they
needed first class was the prequel for
the X-Men films Incorporated different
looks at characters we'd see before the
school was created we know Deadpool 3
follows Deadpool and Cass Wolverine and
some other cameos as he's time jumping
or Multiverse hopping so if we vend
diagram Deadpool 3 In First Class what
scenes would be explored in that Center
first class takes place primarily during
1962 and we saw the Cuban Missile Crisis
that was being orchestrated by Sebastian
Shaw though it was all avoided this
didn't stop the creation of the
Brotherhood of mutants under Eric and
the paralyzing of Charles Xavier so we
ask ourselves what would happen if
Deadpool was there well with his quick
act now and questions later method he
probably kills Sebastian Shaw thus
stopping Eric from receiving the helmet
that th to Charles Charles could use his
powers to stop the military from
releasing those missiles he'd only have
like one minute to do that though and
save them all otherwise they die without
Magneto setting the missiles on a
slightly different course this would
also potentially destroy the idea of the
Brotherhood of mutants or we'd see a
different leader like Mystique soon or
we could see the revisiting of the
hellfire club if you're looking for an
easy way to pamper yourself revamping
your daily hygiene routine is a great
place to start and geology is here to
help geology is a 29 time award-winning
skin hair and body care company
recognizing Men's Health Oprah daily
hype Beast birdie Esquire and GQ G
products use just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologist for decades
geology can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat darker
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging and I am
old as hell if you don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30 second quiz right now if you
use code new Rockstar 100 geology will
give you 100% off of their award-winning
skincare trial set 100% 100% that's in
that that that's all of it that's all of
the that's the the entire enchilada you
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30% off one skin hair or body
products when you add it to your trial
so 100% off plus an additional 30% off
hope you save some champagne because
this is a deal worth celebrating click
the link in the description or go to GE
l g. i/ Rockstar 100 to get started the
hellfire club originally came from the
comics where the Brotherhood wanted
rights for mutants the hellfire club was
more like power hungry they sometimes
worked with and against the X-Men this
this team in first class was led by
Sebastian Shaw and the team was made up
of Emma Frost a zazil and Riptide
eventually bringing an angel now again
ask ourselves how would Deadpool cross
with the hellfire club firstly I don't
think he could stop them on his own and
it depends on how Sebastian Shaw
approaches him since Deadpool is easily
persuaded to do most things we could get
a cameo of Deadpool in this movie
joining them briefly before knowing the
ultimate plan and ending Sebastian right
there before leaving I'm sure that's how
it would go I think the scene we
absolutely 100% will be getting is the
you seen from Wolverine in the bar
because it's an incredible Cameo we all
loved it everybody loves it it's
probably my favorite cameo in any movie
ever Xavier and Eric were so easily
swayed to leave after his immediate
disinterest but that wouldn't fly with
Deadpool since this was around 62
Wolverine was about to be enlisted or
already was enlisted in the vam War I
think he joined in the 70s according to
origin so his reaction could be from
zero interest in being enlisted
regardless Deadpool messing this scene
up can butterfly affect whether or not
Wolverine goes to war if that doesn't
happen he won't join team X so he won't
meet Wade who will absolutely Ely remind
us of killing himself from the last
movie also jumping the war wouldn't have
stopped Wolverine from getting that
adamantium change in Origins since it
came well after leaving team X and
pursuing a normal life regardless I just
think this little nod could be a big
play for Deadpool 3 and why not bring it
in getting the green light from Von and
letting him see the footage makes sense
as a director of one of the X-Men movies
but also this praise is coming directly
from his mouth and rightfully many
people don't trust CB saying this movie
will be a hit and for some reason I
believe Stephen King and Tom Cruz during
the flash hype I don't know why I did
but I did and I'd argue that because of
everything I stated earlier about
Matthew vaugh along with this being a
Deadpool movie I believe his positive
views of the film he was trying to do a
soft reboot for the X-Men series anyways
he cares a lot about the X-Men franchise
and the actors he walked away from X-Men
3 when he realized they were screwing
over Halle Berry he could have simply
said nothing enticing about Deadpool in
this interview or like the New York City
ComicCon aired out some dirty laundry
about what happened behind the scenes
but he did he appreciates what's going
on how it will affect Marvel and what
Ryan Hugh and Shawn bring to the table
so this review I think has a lot of
Merit now to do what I love doing most
at my job really overanalyzing the
phrasing of what Von said because when
you say save the MCU we can be talking a
lot of different things and I know what
you're saying Jessica don't overanalyze
Matthew vaugh has written so many movies
that have gotten a spin-off have gotten
an extra movie this man has been writing
his entire life in the field where
you're supposed to not give away Secrets
I think overanalyzing is okay here
because he knows what he's doing I'm
going to overanalyze that's all I want
to say off my Soap Box okay so when
you're saying save the MCU he could be
saving the MCU and money and numbers we
see the numbers we know what Disney is
doing we see the chess that they're
playing restructuring the development
and creative teams really finally just
recognizing that Marvel Netflix and fox
movies weren't so bad but for real we
need some consistency again and
Spider-Man and Deadpool make us money
these characters bring us money because
they're recognizable characters that can
bring Nostalgia but also can create
something predictable yet fun and easy
to consume so will it really save the
MCU you know in realistic terms no
that's like saying one bucket of cement
will fix every crack in La it'll rely on
the franchise his future it doesn't
happen overnight this can be the seed
for a better tomorrow for sure but
saving the MCU takes more than one
moveie with that being said what if he
meant it literally what if Deadpool
steps out and creates his own path like
She-Hulk I highly doubt we'll get that
exact scene but he did use a time travel
device from cable repaired by negasonic
teenage Warhead to write his timeline
and from Loki's finale we know the TVA
is on to him doing it so technically
there's a world in which Wade fixes the
Disney MCU timeline by adding himself to
it thus saving the MCU it works as a gag
but it also works as like like a
farewell as he enters the Disney World
origin stories come in threes now
Spider-Man Iron Man Thor Venom I'd argue
all of them or Venom will be a
three-part origin story for their
characters deadpol 3 will be his
stepping away from solo movies and into
a shared space with others we might not
even get to see his companions anymore
so we need that pseudo goodbye in the
movie and welcome home like Guardians 3
and no way home did Sean Levy mentioned
in an interview how Ryan is amazing at
wanting Deadpool to lose this could be a
great instrument for a sad ending but a
positive outlook for the future of
Deadpool there are a lot of big take
ways here the biggest is Deadpool save
in the MCU which is a tall order and
requires some more little seeds to
Charter that course I'm excited
regardless and I can't recommend enough
following along with Eric as he breaks
down every X-Men film in chronological
order those videos are super helpful and
just fun to revisit follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu Clem
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love check us out on the
break room the Deep dive and I'll see
you
[Music]
later